MAN: That woke me up out
of a beautiful dream.
Me and pizza with my
girlfriend at this place
near our apartment.
[animal howl]
I think it's a moose.
A moose's mating call.
Dude, just go to her.
Sounds like a match
made in heaven.
[animal howl]
Holy crap, bro.
Oh.
Stupid moose.
[animal howl]
[howls] Ain't nature beautiful?
The moose was at it from like
midnight all the way to an hour
ago, an hour or two ago.
I didn't get a lick
of sleep since then.
He's an ass [bleep].
He's an [bleep] neighbor.
It's like living
next to a fraternity.
Except I couldn't call the cops.
I'm getting really hungry.
Stone crop and grasshoppers
are not cutting it anymore.
And I'm going to
focus more on trapping
and trout line and hunting.
I really need to start catching
fish or kill an animal.
If I don't, they'll be
pulling me out of here.
Wish we could kill moose.
I would've [bleep] murdered
that moose last night.
Oh hell yeah!
Oh [bleep] yeah!
Holy [bleep]!
Oh no, I'm getting
[inaudible] go away.
[bleep] Yeah!
[bleep] fish!
[bleep] Damn it!